there's confusion this morning about the
biden's administration's policy on
thousands of migrants who have been
camping on the southern border of texas
many of the 15 000 migrants have been
deported to their native haiti but
sources tell cbs news more than 1 000
have been allowed into the u.s to ask
for asylum the governor of texas has
been using a line of police cars to keep
the migrants out manuel bajorkas is at
the border patrol station in
bracketville about 30 miles east of del
rio manuel good morning
good morning many of the migrants who
have been allowed to enter the united
states have been issued notices to
appear at an immigration court within 60
days in the meantime the biden
administration says it's working with
south american countries like brazil and
chile to see if they will allow the
return of haitian migrants who have
recently lived there
haitian migrants scrambling to find
their place in line
and arguments break out on the tarmac as
u.s deportation flights ramp up in an
effort to clear out the camp in del rio
in the next 9 to 10 days
more than 1400 haitians have been
deported since sunday and there are
plans for as many as seven flights a day
to their homeland but fewer than 5
thousand migrants remain in the camp as
conditions deteriorate just outside the
bridge camp there are state troopers
lined up as far as the eye can see in
either direction here the point is to
build a wall of vehicles to prevent
anyone from slipping into the u.s
tiffany burrow is director of operations
for an organization in del rio that is
helping migrants who are released into
the u.s we see people who are allowed to
continue on in their asylum seeking
process
but it appears that the majority are not
under the bridge there are a lot more
people
and over here
we're seeing a trickle of them
although
it's in the hundreds so it's a lot for
us too
meanwhile in washington members of the
congressional black caucus met with
white house officials demanding
accountability for what they consider
the mistreatment of migrants we
witnessed cowboys
with their reigns again
whipping
black people
haitians
into the water and we're saying to the
president and everybody else you got to
stop this madness
those lawmakers are also calling for the
removal of border patrol agents who were
seen on horseback intimidating migrants
those agents are currently under
investigation and during that time they
have been reassigned to administrative
duties tony
i mean well comprehensive immigration
reform is stalled on all fronts manny
thank you very much